all right hi everyone welcome to another
wolf language design review this will be
a fairly short one I think today uh part
of our language completeness and
consistency series
all right style sheet definition so so
most of this stuff is mine and just FYI
it's uh there's probably more agenda
items than we're going to go through in
the allotted time today but we'll we'll
make what we can okay so uh the uh in
terms of supporting uh the style sheet
repository
um the uh we have a significant issue
that style definitions
uh can only take certain things and it's
usually the front end is pretty good
about if it receives something it just
doesn't recognize then it preserves it
and you know it may behave badly but it
preserves it and then serializes it back
out uncontaminated uh uncorrupted but
not so as style definitions
uh so I can't do like style definitions
error resource object or something like
that because older front ends will
corrupt these notebooks
um
so what I'm proposing is basically that
uh if if we want to have a resource
object uh uh style sheet that we
reference that essentially it's always
going to live in uh the same sorts that
we use for inherited style sheets
that's a micro notebook effectively yes
and and this is exactly the I mean if
you do format edit style sheet in a new
notebook
uh what happens if I say notebook put of
that thing does it
oops uh yeah what yes well you can see
it right there uh there is a style data
cell you're running a legacy version
because we haven't made a new version
yet and it says I don't know what this
is
but it's not gonna it's not gonna
corrupt it
uh the fonts are the same as they were
in 1987. it's so if you do on your new
notebook you do format edit style sheet
which is this one here no in in your
Untitled 11.
okay uh just in the menus format edit
style sheet
okay and then if you select that uh that
cell uh and uh show cell expression yes
and you'll see this is very much the
same sort of thing we're already doing
for style sheet inheritance all right
the only issue being we don't yet
support resource object but at least if
we serialize this way we're not going to
corrupt anything
okay
and also I think it gives us an
opportunity to do things asynchronously
uh you know we can load up the notebook
and say well we don't know what the
style sheet is yet but it'll kind of
start off with default and then pop in
once we've loaded the reason so let me
just understand something so I mean in
terms of the workflow there'll be the
stylesheet repository and then
you would
presumably in that repository you are
able to either apply a style
sheet to an existing open notebook or
create a new notebook
that is in that style well it's a good
question what the workflow is and I
actually raise one possibility under the
related issues uh which is that I could
come up with some sort of uh uh Auto
interpreted copy and paste kind of like
you know the copy paste cell Expressions
do their Auto interpretation I could
come up with something like that that
basically Auto switches your style sheet
to you know to the given resource object
um so I said it again I got distracted
for a second could you oh it is so uh
you know you copy a cell expression and
you paste and it auto interprets as a
cell Express as a cell yes I could come
up with a magic thing that auto switches
your style sheets and then you know it
would be a click to copy on the on the
resource page so I don't quite
understand what would happen so you
click it on the resource page and then
you would paste it into your notebook
and poof it would kind of uh spray
itself all over your note exactly
exactly yeah I think that's a good idea
it would change your style sheet to be
that expression
yes so if you were if you wanted to add
that style sheet
to The Notebook style sheet as you know
multiple inheritance like if you didn't
want to overwrite everything and you
just wanted to add these styles to maybe
something you'd already defined
that that would require a bit more
knowledge and something different yeah
okay yeah okay but but it's going to be
a little weird this idea about you just
I mean it's like saying
you know it's like some of these UI
things where you're moving files around
you just drop a file in some general
area yeah I mean it is it is weird
because you would be pasting something
and you wouldn't see an actual thing
paste you would see Styles change
um but I mean there are other
applications that allow you to copy and
paste styles
that's true they don't generally work
between applications though right yeah
usually that's only a thing that works
inside of a given application
okay so by the way other security issues
with Dynamics and things like that that
could exist in styles
yes yes there are and I think that uh
the style sheet repository probably
needs some level of curation for that
very fun fun so so then then it will it
will assume it's curated and so we will
assume that it's safe to paste yeah
um
for for the issue of
um not being able to set a resource
object for style definitions uh could
there be like an alternate string syntax
like resource object called no believe
it or not it munches strings too
oh okay yeah because that just seems
like that would be hard for a user to
figure out like set options
what they would put in for style
definitions for a resource object
yeah I mean the only other thing that I
can do is just come up with a brand new
Option yeah right and that's going to be
clunky because then the two options are
fighting one another
right but I think that this if if what
mostly happens is people are getting it
from the repository or a private
repository I think it doesn't they don't
they're not going to see what this code
is underneath
and yeah you know and when you do set
options right it's not like the kernel
directly sets it in in the notebook it
sends a request to the front end so we
could conceivably have something if you
do set options and you set style
definitions to a resource object then
this is true yeah that's a good point
yes I like that sorry what did you just
say so so the idea being that the uh set
options command uh would have a bit of
sugar so if it receives a resource
object it would actually construct this
notebook expression that makes perfect
sense yeah
okay
but then then the main thing is
that the flow is going to be there's
going to be a bunch of sort of samples
of the of the of styles in the style
sheet repository you click to copy you
paste it and it sprays the style of what
you have yeah that's the basic is that
undoable
um like with command Z
not at yeah presence but it wouldn't be
difficult to make it undoable
I almost wonder if if pasting like a an
interface like a button that you know
clicked to apply that and then click to
clear it would be nice I agree oh you
can always just do format style sheet
default too nobody's gonna know to do
that
uh so open up the related issues section
Stephen
uh so I you know I talk about the paste
interpret thing which you've already
been discussing I also wonder whether
um uh things that you recently applied
should show up in the style sheet menu
somewhere why not
yeah down at the bottom or something
yeah okay that's that's easy enough to
do but probably before other but yeah
um
I like the idea of of having I think
it's much less obscure if you get an
interface
in in theory if you had like four style
sheets you wanted to try you could paste
each of them and they'd have their own
button that's part of why I think
pasting a button might be useful all
right okay but so this has to be
developed and yeah together well and and
and I I imagine that there could be an
interface that lives in the other uh or
the stylesheet Chooser dialogue uh
that's not necessarily going to happen
right away but uh but I wanted to uh
even though you know the style sheet
repository may not be ready on this time
frame I wanted to start building and
support in the front end for in
anticipation of these guys so we so we
wouldn't have an interface in 13 3 but I
can get the other Machinery in okay so
hold on there's also the question of
um
uh the um
uh in the cloud how this works yes
and I think the style sheet support in
the cloud is inadequate at this time but
hopefully we'll improve but then there's
the question of how all these steps work
yeah okay yeah well anyway we've got the
beginnings of this and we can see
there's not it's not devastatingly
hopeless
to have the at least for the desktop to
have the Styles appropriately used but
we should check with the cloud team I
don't know whether there's anybody heard
from that team today
um about how this can work yeah so they
they do support private style sheets and
this is basically a flourish on a
private style sheet so I'm hopeful that
it's not going to be a lot of effort for
them
all right let's move on to oh you're not
using a recent
build okay well I mean tell me what to
do I can go to a prototype build
okay and I think for the resource folks
I think that was all that we needed you
for
thank you man thanks thanks
um
okay undelighted
Sandra is commenting on uh live stream
that um uh he doesn't like the name and
we also had terrible trouble with the
name yesterday where does that name come
from uh so it was it was a random name
that a developer added to it which I did
not change because frankly I thought
about uh you know I thought about trying
to come up with a better name and I
couldn't come up with one yeah okay fine
but okay so it was added in 2016 I found
from my archive yeah yeah it's it it was
uh it's been there for a while
um right okay but but but okay so what
should the name be so is there a name
for I mean is there an official name for
the squigglies that show up in I am not
aware of an official name I've never
seen a name for these things
um
and I'm uncomfortable with using the
word squiggly because one of the things
we've discussed is having variations of
these things that wouldn't necessarily
be squiggly I agree
the wavy red underline it says and um
uh
wow
even Microsoft refers to it not the red
squiggly underline
they call it a squiggly too
uh so I mean it is related to
highlighting I know
it's not what we think of as you know
like a yellow highlighter sort of thing
but it is related to the conceptually
well I mean so the question is could it
be a feature of highlighted
well highlighted uh does not correspond
to a front-end option we we would still
need a front-end option name and maybe
you decide the front end option name can
be a bad name and that's okay
um
well but okay so hold on a second
highlighted right now is a wrapper that
is a symbolic rapper that stays whereas
under
lighted no I'm very confused
underlighted is also a symbolic rapper
that stays or not it depends on your
definition of stays
um
right I mean yeah but that's a form will
evaluate to Identity effectively it'll
remove the head on re-evaluation
right and uh oh let's remind ourselves
what we're using this for okay so for
example it's used in the code assistance
system to indicate potential errors
correct but right right uh but one thing
that was said in yesterday's live stream
which isn't quite accurate is that uh uh
that you can't
really assume that uh oh you can just
put it into editable code and then
people can edit it and everything will
be fine because uh and this is true with
highlighted as well uh that uh you know
the thing which does the highlighting
imposes structure
uh and that structure
uh might drop away on evaluation but it
exists for purposes of editing
I mean but the interpretation function
is basically pound one right so if
you're editing it that'll still be there
right right but but but but it means
that you know you have to you know
what's inside uh yes the Highlight has
to be evaluatable
that's true yeah I mean you can't you
know if you add you know plus one to the
example here you can't have the plus
inside the highlighted and the one
outside the highlighted uh
sub-expression exactly exactly
okay
but whereas the underlighted thing does
not have to be a syntactically complete
sub-expression or is that not the case
well in fact the way that under lighted
is used in code assist uh and is that it
might not be uh syntactically complete
at all it might you might be underlining
under lighting an operator
right and the way underlayed it was
implemented it is like highlighted now
we could change the implementation no I
think we've got a box level
implementation that can span different
sub-expressions and we've got a language
level implementation which is a pure
syntactic correct because there's
nothing you can do at the language level
unless you're down at the level of boxes
you cannot deal with some tactically
incorrect or non-structured things no
that that's not at all correct right I
mean okay the right the output is going
to be some boxy thing right which you
can copy and then you could edit it
and then you could edit it to not be
synthetically correct maybe you're
saying that's not a useful workflow but
you know so I'm suggesting that we have
two levels of this right just like
highlighted is always highlighting a
sub-expression but syntactically
meaningful sub-expression actually it's
more than syntactically meaningful it's
you know semantically evaluationally
meaningful sub-expression
because but that but but but yeah but
that that that that has nothing to do
with the point that John and I are
making
okay which is you might want to edit
that that output
and you can you know we could make it so
that what's inside the under light is
doesn't correspond to a sub expression
if we wanted to now maybe we don't want
to but I understand I understand you're
saying that you could allow
that the Box expression I mean I don't
understand why the thing isn't making it
the same box expression that it would
make
were it to be generating raw boxes but
the boxes happen to have a complete
sub-expression being the highlighted
thing
if that makes sense
right look the the number one issue here
is we need a name analog to highlight
analogous to highlighted
that and I'm not quite sure why we don't
have a second argument to highlight it
that is just the manner of highlighting
well so that's
possible like I said we would still have
to have you know the front end option
name and the front-end option name could
continue to be underlighted and we just
don't care about that because it's sort
of in a ghetto of front adoption names
is it an option name or is it a setting
it's it's a front end uh well it's a sub
option actually it's a sub option of
what very uh
as right there in the agenda with
complete with
screenshot and link to said ref page
wait a minute where are we looking here
comes I don't understand document oh I
see documented here
right on font variations okay but but
styling the
I mean it's it's amusing to call it
under light in that case but
I mean if that case is always going to
be the red I mean where does the color
of that get set
that's the value of the underlying
specification
oh the color used for highlighting yep
so you can't say under light goes to
true but for the the wrapper function we
made we had a default color which is red
corresponding to the spell checker color
okay so look the obvious thing
would be since we got underline
the obvious name will be under wavy
or something because an underline is a
line underneath something
yeah so there is you know aside from the
shape there is another fundamental
difference which is that underline is
always the color of the fonts
whereas I see under lights is quite
often not the color of the font and it
certainly you know the point being it
has an independent color specification
it's a weird name but it's not I mean we
have been using it for a number of years
and it's not obviously
uh
well look it's all is it always going to
be a wavy line
so we have talked about I mean one
specific proposal we had although I
think that proposal may have aged out
and you know never got implemented but
was a railroad track version uh uh kind
of uh like like slant you know like a
row of slanted lines that look like uh
slanted railroad ties
um I mean if we want maybe you know
maybe we
right I mean we could have a second
argument to highlight it which is
I don't know again we'd have to come up
with a name for it but
um and right we could have a string name
that's you know just the
uh
well but we've only got background
colors highlighted has specifications
for background color does not have a
specification it's going to get weird
because it is a
it's a full background highlighting
right
look I mean this is sort of an emphasis
thing
we could call it
emphasis line color
or emphasis line Style
we could call this thing an emphasis
line
that's not ridiculous
okay
uh so then that option would become
emphasis line Style
and then the style will be a color or we
could generalize that to um uh to
something different
yeah I mean we don't support this right
now but one you could imagine you know
like thickness or something like that as
well right I mean it is adding the style
is a bit weird right I mean none of
those things have style and yeah but
none of them have they're all true false
uh no some caps type is not true false
[Music]
well but it but it says type at the end
it's okay
right as opposed to just being a
statement
okay
um
let's try emphasis line Style
I mean and we're describing it as a line
or emphasis underline style maybe that
would be the best a better the most
explicit thing to call it emphasis
underline Style
so the the noun form of the thing is an
emphasis on the line
hello what well
um
okay
let's take a very quick look at these
other things I'm really gonna have to go
in a second here okay I I uh I had demos
that were totally working and then uh a
a massive demo breakage on this thing
came through which is a shame because I
really wanted to show you this but the
point being we have uh support for
nested action menus this is this is the
syntax that we're using right now I'm
hugely in favor of the syntax but of
course I want to run it by you
seems sensible to me
okay I mean if if I don't think it means
I don't think the only the only thing
that could happen is there's an
ambiguity here obviously right
it evaluates the right hand side in in
the Legacy version but the evaluation of
a list generally is not that useful
well I mean you're saying
the the that a particular
action element
yes because an action menu is doing side
effect things yes right a list is kind
of a a blah you know side effectively
it's not very useful because exactly see
the list yes I mean it's not even really
ambiguous because it's Raw versus rule
delayed
um well to be clear it does work with
rule delayed and it's not like I'm gonna
you know we're gonna punish users if
they use rule delayed but uh yeah my
better guidance is to use rule
right
um so sorry I was trying to quiet a
ringing phone so I missed a transition
between the the those two agenda items
did we come up with a name for the
head version
oh we didn't
okay
right we well we could call it emphasis
underlined
that works
it's a bit long but I don't think it's
terrible
okay
okay yeah
it's a little weird
um I just call it emphasized
or is that too
you know it's not obviously wrong
it's not obviously wrong particularly if
emphasized
had multiple you know different second
arguments that give gave different forms
of emphasis
it could activate any of these font
variations for instance
outline Shadow yes
right so maybe in a maybe in an initial
version it just takes
the color and uses emphasize but then we
could extend it to understand these
other things or and even combinations
thereof
but that seems reasonable yeah
okay we should wrap it up for now thank
you yeah yeah the the image margins
thing is uh is a bit it will take a bit
of time to work I'm sure yes uh and the
other stuff is not as urgent so
all right look forward to seeing it all
see you all soon thank you to folks on
the live stream for their comments as
well okay great